[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at our individual
tables of either dining or placed into
your living room Rhett we are going to
have another discussion because if this
gets don't stop because we're in our
homes it's not that much no it doesn't
still what still working you you you you
think this is work I don't even have
pants on this is a nice outlet today you
know what what today's gonna be a
positive outlet just like you can sit
down and watch a movie and you can
escape from the reality of what's going
on and there's I mean there's some good
news there's a lot of bad news there's a
lot there's still a lot of troubling
news's there's things to be worried
about but you can escape into a book you
can escape into a show you can escape
into a movie and right now you can
escape into an ear biscuits about movies
yeah we're gonna do one of our top 10
favorites episodes we're doing top 10
favorite movies for each one of us
personally going through our list we've
had fun with this before what else did
we do we did TV shows we did TV shows
we also did game shows like spiezio of
course yeah so well I'll say a few
things about it it was incredibly
difficult to make this list because as
I've said many times about my lists of
favorites is that I don't I don't have
like a favorite movie I have like a
collection of movies and once I started
trying to narrow down to 10 I started
feeling really bad about the ones that I
was leaving off of the top 10 so I have
a pretty long list of honorable mentions
I'm pretty sure you do as well I have
some honorable mentions the thing that
it's not that I had difficulty narrowing
it down as much as I actually had
difficulty accessing some of those I oh
I I remembered one that would be like hi
up on my list and I can't believe I
almost forgot about this movie it's been
so long since I've seen it but it's not
just what we think are the best movies
ever but at least for me I rank the
movies that were most personally
impactful the movies that were most
meaningful to me for a variety of
reasons which i think is kind of what we
did with the television show thing as
well yeah it's more about I mean
favorite doesn't necessarily mean best
best right although I would say the
majority of the movies that I ended up
letting make the top 10 were the ones
that with few exceptions I still think
these are just incredible there's
nothing to become on this list it's not
an incredible film right but it might
not be that they're all 98 percent or
above on Rotten Tomatoes you know that's
that wasn't my criteria but also the way
that I kind of tried to access the
memories which I have a horrible memory
unless I wrote something down is I went
to lists of movies right you know and so
I'm there's probably there might be
something that you accessed through your
memory that wouldn't have made like top
100 yeah I went like top 100 all genres
and like went through all them to kind
of like Reax s different movies yeah I
did one that's not on there anyway one
of the things that I realized was I've
fallen out of the habit of watching
movies I don't there's been different
eras of movie watching and I think it
will become clearer in my list as to win
these movies meant the most to me like
when I first watched them and what can
what compels me to go back and watch
them but you know as television has
evolved
I find myself watching more television
the movies at home and not going to the
theater or going to theater for a
different reason or going with different
people like with younger people that
type of thing has changed my movie going
habits but in this current situation if
there's ever been an opportunity to go
back and re-watch movies or to introduce
you know your partner or your
your kids to movies that were special to
you now is a great time that we're
looking to do that now we're just
looking for opportunities to do things
in movies they take a good chunk of time
so like I guess you can just consider
this an entire recommendation episode as
we go through these do you want to start
let's get into it
sure of course we're starting with
number 10 and working our way to number
one and again of course I don't know
your list and you don't know my list so
write my number ten favorite movie of
all time
is the good the bad and the ugly really
the good and the bad the ugly I mean I
own that movie on DVD but I couldn't
have even told you that you've watched
it what are you crazy
you know you didn't watch it with me
I've what I watched every sin every
Clint Eastwood movie multiple times oh
not just like a fistful of dollars and a
few dollars more and but no I watch the
dollars trilogy which incidentally this
movie is considered the third and final
installment in that trilogy even though
it was brick basically just marketed as
that because it was a it was a spaghetti
western it was an Italian produced and
directed movie and the reason I I love
this I wanted to have a I wanted first
of all I wanted to have a Western in
there because okay I love the love the
genre yeah but this is the most I'm
actually surprised it is at least not on
your honorable mentions because this is
the most iconic film score of all time
that's my mine yeah so Ennio Morricone
what he basically this is that class
like so many so many things that you
take for granted both in film scores but
also in filmmaking like
yeah you know this soundtrack even if
you don't know that you know this
soundtrack trying to do then with my
head it sounds a little bit like what
link try to do there but it's like yeah
and there's like whip sounds and stuff
like that all that stuff that you just
sound like maybe top two or three movie
soundtracks at all times definitely but
the movie itself
you gotta settle in because it's a
different type of pacing the first ten
and a half minutes there is no dialogue
ten and a half minutes of no dialogue
and the shots are incredible like
there's all these shots of just eyeballs
and there's shots incredibly why the
cinematography is absolutely amazing out
so I did a little research and learned
that Clint Eastwood was so frustrated
with making this movie that he never
worked with the director again because
the director was so meticulous about
like you see the final product in the
way that all the team he worked the
actors so hard to get all of these
different shots that cleaning so it was
like I'm never working with this guy
again and people kind of looked down on
the whole spaghetti western Sergio Leone
I can't remember names I looked it up
just a super weird time in filmmaking
history and that all of a sudden they
started making a bunch of westerns in
Italy and then like they were some you
know like Spain was involved in some
ways and I don't know I mean also the
whole thing is overdubbed so if you go
back and watch this you're gonna be like
what yeah they 80-yard the entire movie
and it's super obvious but there's just
something about all the elements that
come together to just make it iconic for
me and the the face of the three-way
face off scene at the end is pretty
pretty memorable if you can last that
long yeah I think anybody I mean I
understand that it's a certain taste but
for me it's it's so iconic and it stands
on its own and it influenced so much of
filmmaking yeah but that point on that
it's just I just I loved it I did own it
I actually might enjoy watching like you
know the outlaw Jesse Wells or something
like that more as a movie and then I
loved some of the like unforgive
later like 90s so no other Western made
your list nope
tombstone no tombstones not it not on
the list I thought - stone would be on
your list okay my number 10 released in
2004 I this is a movie that I had
forgotten about but it it popped up as I
was doing some browsing and I was like I
think this needs to go on my list it
barely made it but here it is at number
10 Napoleon Dynamite
it's an honorable mention for me okay it
got it got close to making it on the
list for sure Napoleon Dynamite jared
has movie you know he in made a short
film and then it I think that's what was
it slam dance which was like the
companion Film Festival to Sundance and
like so I'm pretty sure I'm right about
that then they turned it into a
full-length movie and it was it was
based on his experiences in growing up
in Idaho and like the llama that's in it
is his his mom's or his grandma's llama
because she really had one and last
night didn't have anything to do and I
was like living in Lando and I were
going we're gonna watch something I was
like that's what watch a movie I think
you're like Napoleon Dynamite it's
number 10 on my list I'd like for you to
watch it and of course I hadn't watched
it in a long time and it just it is so
specifically strange you know and yeah
it's also innovative for its time too
it's don't like many people have tried
to do that quirky thing including Jared
Hess himself has tried to recreate the
magic that he sort of found in Napoleon
Dynamite and that's been difficult for
him to do well because it was right I
really love not to Libre I like my whole
family had watched that we may have
watched it twice over the years Jack
Black is hilarious it's it's a really
good movie so I would say
it in in in lille and Lando's opinion is
a much better moving in Napoleon
Dynamite because at like 10 or 13
minutes in they they were like dad is
this the movie but they were like it's
something gonna happen
cuz it's just these strange characters
just being themselves and there's not a
lot that's really happening there's I
mean they they couldn't keep watching it
I had to turn it off and we hadn't
gotten to any sort of question or
conflict you're kidding yeah they
weren't into it they love matches
approached my kids have what first of
all my kids end up watching a lot of
movies without me like especially a lock
like I'll be like hey have you seen
so-and-so classic movies oh yeah he just
watches a bunch of stuff on his own so
the really dynamite
kids have watched that and they they
liked it I'm a fan I weren't as nervous
as I was Don Verdean biblical
archaeologist and then well I think the
thing we like about jared has is that he
if if we were to make movies we've
always thought especially because at
that time like 2004 when that one came
out I think we were thinking we were
trying to figure out what does this
career gonna look like and where's this
eventually gonna go and I think we
always assumed that it would end at
making movies and maybe it will link
maybe it will one day but we had this
vision that oh the way that he's kind of
drawing on the weird quirky stuff from
him to hit his life in his childhood and
the way that he puts that on screen in
very specific ways is just how we
imagined that we would always make it
was a different type of comedy that's
why I had to be on my list I felt like
because it was so inspiring for me
and for both of us because it was a
specific strain of comedy that we had
never experienced that every choice was
a comedic choice and it came together in
a way that was like it was so odd that
it became cool in spite of itself even
the music cues and like the composition
everything was just delightfully strange
and I think it gave us confidence that
those instincts communicants thinks that
we had that were kind of kindred to his
was something that people could day and
I it gave us more confidence to to
explore our comedic voice so that's why
I had to make the list for me okay
I'll pick up with number nine in one
second first we do want to take a short
break let you know that we've got pop
sockets people we at mythical calm you
can go and pick up pop sockets we've got
the mythical pop socket we've got the
GMM pop sock come on I'm gonna put it up
prop up your phone hop now we don't have
it on our phones right now because we're
gonna sell these check this out
I mean very satisfying the thing about a
pocket is that it's basically it's still
the only acceptable form of a fidget toy
you know it's kind of far - and it feels
good so again kind of far - a mythical
calm that didn't the words mythical
meadow I'm not gonna come out of my
mouth exactly right there's also eight
we don't have our hands on it right now
there's a feel good mythical morning pop
socket so every time you know we're on
and hold on to it it feels good and you
know what it feels good pop it I did get
that actually I just remember I got one
of those in the mail I believe and I'm
in it's just in a package sorry
crew hi mythical crew who sent that to
me on time I don't have it but it's it
feels good and it looks good go to
mythical calm I got all types of stuff
including pop sockets we will we will
just let's get poppin if you want to
know what's poppin go to mythical calm
okay back to the list we're to your
number nine if you've lost track already
number nine what I consider to be the
perfect movie perfect movie and it's
only number nine The Godfather
okay okay I thought I thought that one
of these would make your list I mean
people say God specifically all better
well again there's a there's another
trilogy as you might imagine on my list
there's probably at least one on your
list and I just picked the first one
from I'm just picking the first movie
from the trilogy and Godfather 2 is
incredible God 4/3 is everybody sort of
agrees it's not as good but I love a
gangster movie
absolutely and so obviously the
Godfather was Francis Ford Coppola and
then Scorsese kind of came in and has
taken over the mantle of being the
making the perfect gangster movie
Goodfellas speaking of Scorsese was
almost took this spot on the list
because Goodfellas is funnier than the
Godfather and I also think it's a
perfect movie by the way and it's sort
of the modern gangster movie but a lot
of the same characters it's just you had
the addition of Joe Pesci yeah
what they're playing the same characters
you're not playing this no no no no no
but the same Astor's yeah yeah yeah De
Niro you know is so I love the epic sort
of like sweeping multi-generational
nature of a really good gangster movie
and again that's what they did in the
Irishman where they kind of took him
through his life and I just sit there
and I just kind of just completely I
become engrossed with this and I
remember the first time I watched The
Godfather which I don't remember how old
I was but I was a teenager and I very
rarely have gotten lost in something and
just been like because a lot of people
are like man there's movies are so long
like a Scorsese movie and the Godfather
I don't know how long the first one is
there all along but like he doesn't it
doesn't matter I could just take it I
could watch it
I could watch like a 12 hour version of
it because everything about it is
perfect the writing the acting the score
the cinematography I just don't think
there's any misses at all although I was
surprised to learn
that Marlon Brando two things about him
he actually put cotton balls in his
cheeks when he did his audition for the
role uh-huh
because he wanted his face to kind of
like a bulldog more so than it already
did and then for the movie they they had
a dentist make like a prosthetic that
goes in his mouth that like pushes his
cheeks out and Gudrun drop that way he
talked but he also is such a weird dude
he didn't memorize any of his lines for
the movie he read them off cue cards so
to learn that the lead actor in one of
the best movies of all time wasn't
really even acting in the traditional
sense Wow was it was a little surprising
but so you're saying that a gangster
well okay you don't have to be a
gangster movie didn't make your top ten
no gangster movie and I you know I think
a lot of people may be thinking link you
you've got a reputation of being the guy
who hasn't seen the movies and you know
what that's true especially like all of
the the movies that everybody's seen
from the 80s you know which is why we
made that viewmaster thing for the
mythical society that put me in these
movies I've never seen like Ferris
Bueller's Day Off
but yeah I've seen the Godfather I've
seen the Godfather Part two but there
was a there was a stint in college where
I realized I needed to go back and watch
these movies because in my house growing
up we just didn't watch we didn't rent
that many movies or watch that many
movies in your house I just think it
that was like a that was a big thing
right and know a lot of those watch them
together but you would also watch the
movies on your own but you rent those
VHS of The Godfather and watch that so
in college I watched those I watched you
know Space Odyssey 2001 I you know I
watched all the things that like oh no
so 2001 didn't make your top ten no that
was an honorable mention for me I was
sure that that movie would make your top
ten I had that
had that kick where I took an intro to
film class my sophomore year and I
really felt convicted to go back and
watch the greatest movies of all time
and we would watch a lot of them
together and there was a really cool you
know video store there where a lot of
you could rent for a dollar remember
that yeah so I watched them all so
closely together that they didn't have a
lasting personal impact there are some
from that time in my life but it's it
says a lot more about me than it does
about the movie so no no no gangster
movies in my list okay what is your
number 9 my number 9 is from 2014 I I
was making my list and I realized I
didn't have a Marvel movie on my list
and I feel like that if I'm gonna see a
movie now like without exception I go to
the theater to see a Marvel movie
because my entire family's into it it's
a way that we connected we got a lot of
really great memories around watching
movies we watched infinity war and when
it was over we had reservations for
dinner and Lily was in tears and I was
like emotionally ripped apart and we we
didn't even go we didn't even eat dinner
we just went home you know so I felt
like I had I had Marvel had to be
represented on my on my list somewhere
so at number 9 the only Marvel movie on
my list guardians of the galaxy
that's my favorite Marvel movie I mean
infinity war the first Avengers like oh
there's a lot of ones that are special
but guardians is just my favorite it's
just it's the funniest it was so
surprising because it yeah I wasn't I'm
not a comic book guy so I wasn't really
familiar with the characters so I my
expectations were low but then they were
blowing out of the water and it just
continues to deliver
with every sequel I can't wait for the
next one yeah so guardians of the galaxy
was on my original just like my long
list I kind of I so I guess you could
technically say it's on my my honorable
mentions but it didn't really have it I
knew it wasn't gonna make it into the
top ten
yeah but it is for me as a guy who
doesn't really like comic book movies
it is easily the best franchise Marvel
franchise for me and I think that's why
it's on my list for the reasons if it's
almost on your list plus because reasons
I love Marvel it one of the things that
happens in Marvel movies that is
frustrating to me is just I'm just not
the whole action thing is not it's not
super appealing to me and like following
a bunch of different like I like the
Avengers and there's incredibly well
done but like just things get too
complicated it's not like it's difficult
to follow what's happening in the
Avengers I'm not saying that it's not
like memento or something but it's
there's emotional engagement in the
entire it's a little too complicated and
too complex for me to like find out what
I was supposed to attach to but for
guardians of the galaxy I attached you
know I find that there's an emotional
connection the soundtrack we play the
soundtrack it's by far the most played
movie soundtrack in our house as
guardians of the galaxy it's going all
the time because you know what Chris
Pratt listens to in the yeah movie is
it's incredible and it's super funny so
yeah I definitely thought about it but I
just couldn't I couldn't give it a top
10 spot all right so where you at number
eight I I'm Alma I'm positive this is
not on your list unless you unless
you're you've got something that you've
never told me
The Wizard of Oz Wow right okay yeah oh
yeah easily
okay easily and this for me is if you're
if you're a 42 year old person or
somewhere along those lines you remember
the Wizard of Oz coming on every single
year on television
and for me it was this incredibly
special like getting by myself and
watching The Wizard of Oz was this
almost spiritual experience there's
something absolutely magical about that
story I mean it is recognized as one of
the best movies of all time
uh most people's list but that's not why
I chose it that's why I remembered it
but I'll say oh yeah Wizard of Oz like I
would there's something about it's such
a it's such an early time in sort of
cinematic history they were able to
bring this fantasy world to life and
when you watch it you can kind of see
like oh I can kind of tell that they're
just in sort of a big room and that
castle is painted on a wall but you can
still tell that it it was flooring for
anyone the first time they saw it and
even as a kid I can access that memory
you know the first time I saw it and
still being transported there yeah well
one of my favorite things that one of my
favorite genres of literature and one of
my favorite genres of movie is the our
fantasy movies where there is a
connection to the real world right so
even though I don't like you know the
Chronicles of Narnia is not on my list
because I didn't really like the movies
I loved the books as a kid yeah and the
reason the Chronicles of Narnia
connected with me so much is because it
actually established a connection
between the real world in England with
this fantasy world as opposed to like
Game of Thrones which is just a fantasy
it's a world building fantasy thing
which is awesome but the idea that you
can actually find a thin place somewhere
in the world and actually move into the
fantasy world it's been something that
has been fascinating for me since I was
a kid and I remember like walking in the
woods and like looking in trees and
there's like this is this how you get to
the fantasy place and even though I know
that she was technically just in a dream
which is unfortunate that's how it ends
spoiler alert just the idea that this
girl from Kansas the real world with her
little dog goes into this absolutely
magical place that was
presented in this incredible way it's
just it's definitely I almost put it
higher on the list because it looms so
large and my childhood I gotta say now I
do feel a little guilty for not putting
it on my list because I I remember that
feeling of realizing it was coming on
television again when I was a kid and
being so excited
it was gripping and it wasn't the type
of thing that you you only watched half
of it once you were in it you were in it
you're like oh this is a good part this
is a good part and in for to hold up
that well is absolutely amazing
it's like annika okay so my number eight
is a Wes Anderson movie now if I were to
rank my favorite filmmakers I think Wes
Anderson may be my favorite filmmaker he
may take my number one spot so it kind
of it this was difficult for me that I
had to narrow III I ain't I don't I
guess can I guess which one you chose I
had to put one on my list and I didn't
put one higher than this yeah you can
guess okay well let me before I guess
let me just say that I knew that a Wes
Anderson film would be on your list and
a Wes Anderson film almost made it on my
list because I don't like what's that
request understand as much as you do but
he is he's definitely in my top five
favorite filmmakers however none of his
movies made the list for me and the
movie that I would and was almost on my
list at number 10 and almost knocked off
the good and bad the ugly is one I'm
sure it's not on your list I bet you'd
say fantastic mr. Fox no I always said
Rushmore Rushmore is great and I was I
was almost gonna put that on for the
kids last night and then I realized it's
rated R and I didn't want Lana to watch
it but so I think you chose I think that
you owe us more but I thought about it
you either chose I know you either shows
the Royal Tenenbaums or The Life Aquatic
and I think you chose a life aquatic you
are right I saw I wish I would have seen
the life aquatic in theaters I don't
know why I didn't do that it came out in
2004
Rushmore came out in 1998 Tenenbaums
came out closer to the Life Aquatic I
think Tenenbaums was the first movie
that I watched of Wes Anderson and then
I went back and watched the the previous
ones it's a great movie great acting and
it was it's so striking the the the
visual voice that he has and it really
resonates with me I mean it's not not
just the the meticulous control that he
applies to every single thing just
seeing his process when watching the
movie I delight in that and I think
that's um it just makes me feel you know
it's like it's like a well-oiled machine
or well cleaned room you know it
resonates with me to see everything so
perfectly symmetrical and then the way
that the comedy doesn't the first time
you watch it you're like is that I find
that funny but is that supposed to be
funny
and of course once you understand you
know it is yeah it's a well that's
that's why that's why he's one of my
favorite filmmakers
I mean I've obviously the aesthetic
stuff that you're talking about but for
me it is the effortless comedy and the
way and also his casting is is better
than anybody in terms of comedic casting
knowing knowing who's going to be funny
without trying it was master he's a
master of that the reason why I chose
life aquatic even though some people
will rank it really low on their Wes
Anderson lists it was more whimsical it
was it didn't have there's a in a lot of
Wes Anderson's movies there's an
underpinning of sadness and there's a
lot of comedy that comes from that I
wouldn't call it dark comedy but it's
like sad comedy
The Life Aquatic was kind of a refrain
from that it was a it was it was more
whimsical it you know it was I mean Bill
Murray's character was tapped into so
much of what you get with Bill Murray
that like it's it wasn't he was very
morose as a character but it wasn't I
never felt sorry for him I always felt I
just thought it was hilarious
and exploring that world you know with
the cutaways of the ship and everything
it was just it was just more fun
throughout than Tenenbaum so if I was
gonna sit down and rewatch it I find
myself l myself going back to that one
more often for those reasons yeah I
think the rink the reason it didn't make
my list is because I can I appreciate
all those things about Wes Anderson and
I find it's incredibly enjoyable to
watch his movies and you like everything
about it there's something you can keep
finding that you're enjoying but the one
thing that it doesn't do for me is I
don't get emotionally invested in his
characters in the same way however the
character I got most invested in is you
know Schwartzman and Rushmore
interestingly and so I think that that's
why it was my favorite but yeah it's
just more like it's almost just like and
it's a filmmaking it's just an
experience and watching great filmmaking
it's like going to an amusement park
it's like I never forget that I'm
watching a movie though I think that's
the thing as I never forget that I'm
watching a movie it draws attention
unlike some else it sounds strange yeah
yeah give me your number son okay my
number seven again I wonder when we're
gonna get some crossover because I don't
think this is we're there yet number
seven for me is the Princess Bride again
this is this is a lot of people want to
people a lot of people's favorite movie
and I again it was one of those that the
first time I watched it I was just like
if this is what movies are I this I want
to make I want to make movies you know
it has it's got that adventure quality
but it's The Princess Bride for me is
is just the peak of sort of fantasy
comedy doesn't go all the way into like
a Monty Python place that it's just
completely unhinged gets pretty close in
a couple of places but again there's
just something about the tone first of
all I'm a huge Rob Reiner fan and he's
done so many different things and then
once I read which I've recommended this
book before I recommend it again but as
you wish book yeah the audio is actually
great - yeah audiobooks got a bunch of
the cast talking and so cut freaking
Andre the Giant in it but again I just I
just love the way it came together I
love there's so many epic moments in it
and again it's just I just get lost in
it I love the Princess Bride I wish I
would have seen it as a kid I don't know
I was deprived you know I saw it
III don't think I saw it until after
college and it's just a different thing
and like I could see I could see the
everything you're saying but I couldn't
fully experience it because it doesn't
quite hold up if you're not accessing
the first time you saw it when you're
younger I think yeah well did you know
that the actor that they originally
wanted to play the giant was not Andre
the Giant first Fezzik is that is the
giant snake it was Arnold Schwarzenegger
oh wow
was the first choice just not enough
first of all it's huge enough like Andre
giant had this cuteness that made it
work well he also had this giant this
yeah horse the [ __ ] actually doesn't
have he's but he's a he's ripped he's my
pony on a bar very high
actual giant which is on my yes but yeah
because the whole again you got to read
the book because well not the book that
is based on the you know the princess
bribe by William gold a goldman Golda
Goldman anyway I have never read the
book but people said it was one of those
things like oh you can't adapt this book
and they had tried many different times
kind of like did you I don't even
realize until recently they're they're
dune
another book that they said could never
be adapted as being uh it's being made
into a film right now I've heard that
but it thoughts but anyway it it took 12
years the twelve years have passed
between the time that they were talking
about Arnold being Fezzik to when it
actually happened because it took so
long to get the film going and by that
time Horsham [ __ ] wasn't just a
massive start it would have been
incredibly odd and weird for ya just
play the giant and so they got a
pro-wrestler to do it who ended up being
is one of my favorite parts in any movie
ever my number seven movie is the first
movie I ever remember seeing in the
theater I don't know if it actually was
but it probably was this was 1984 so I
was six if I saw it late in the theater
maybe depending on when Atlanta that
could have been seven my dad took me to
see Indiana Jones and the Temple of Doom
and in a recent episode
well maybe months back I did talk about
how we watched all of the Indiana Jones
movies with the kids so I introduced
them to him and they were enthralled as
well now you could make the argument
that Raiders of the Lost Ark is it is a
better movie I would I would make that
argument and that's why and Raiders of
the Lost Ark is on my honorable Nations
but even though Indiana Jones called
Great Temple of Doom is a lot darker
Temple of Doom is not as funny but it
holds a special place because I don't
know why my dad took me to see this
movie it was rated PG and then because
but because of the public reaction to
the the darkness of gremlins and Temple
of Doom Spielberg lobbied that they come
up with a new rating which became pg-13
and they changed the rating of Temple of
Doom to pg-13 one of the first movies
that got that rating so I just remember
seeing the heart come out of that guy's
chest and covering my eyes in the
theater and being absolutely
horrified and it was amazing watching
the movie back I couldn't believe how
endlessly entertaining it was one scene
to the next you're just thrown as he's
he tumbles from one thing to the next
and it's absolutely endless it seems
like you you you think it can't get
better than this the action can't get
more exciting than this and then it
happens and it's I mean there are some
problems you know that they're the
cultural portrayals of you know and then
like there's the white Savior thing that
I'm not gonna see and it doesn't have
its problems and I'm not I'm not
defending those but it holds a special
place in my heart because it scared the
crap out of me as a child and my kids
loved it when they watched it scared the
crap out of Lando and he loved it
a few weeks ago so I definitely feel
like like I said Raiders of the Lost Ark
was was very close to making my top 10 I
kind of felt like I had to I wanted to
put a Spielberg movie in my top 10
because that's that's how I ended up
kind of approaching this list in a lot
of ways it was like I started realizing
the the filmmakers that I liked their
their body of work the most and I was
like okay I'm gonna give you one film
but I just I couldn't do it as much as I
loved the Indiana Jones franchise and it
does loom very large in my childhood and
you got wasted dinner scene where
they're like eating the bugs and the
monkey brains there's so many iconic
says that's that's GMM right there man
it's like the thing that I was horrified
by as a child is something that became a
cornerstone of my career path I've got a
connection to this movie man okay my
number six is but by far my most recent
movie okay I don't have them I don't
have my years in here I should have done
that but this is just for a couple years
ago few years ago
get out yeah I said get out was a
an honorable mention of mine like I knew
you had to hit horror and I knew even
independent from that you had to hit get
out because yeah well yeah so it'll
culturally you might think yeah you
would assume there be more horror on my
I like horror movies a lot but and I
enjoy watching them probably more than
any movie because I just enjoy the idea
of getting scared especially in a group
of people and now lock and I every
single Saturday night is horror movie
night in the two of us just go down it
to the garage where we've got a
television and no one else will get
scared because no one else can hear
what's happening but we've watched a
bunch of ridiculous horror movies but
anyway did you think about us or is it
clearly get out over us dude house
better than us yeah I mean I I mean I
there's so many things I love everything
about both movies but get out was one of
the most enjoyable movie going
experiences I've ever had like the first
time I saw it in the theater I was
feeling so many things all at once when
I was watching it the first thing I was
feeling was this is super scary and it's
like kidding me but this is super funny
and like a like a really funny like a
like a like a I'm laughing as much as I
am kind of cringing in fear and then the
whole time I'm thinking Jordan Peele
make this you know it's just like Jordan
Peele
of key and Peele comedy duo this guy has
gone and created this perfect movie
there was this there was like a
combination of fact there was a
fascination but also looking at an
incredible jealousy at the same time to
just think dude this this guy went off
and did this thing that man I mean like
this is an incredible accomplishment for
anyone but this dude was just over here
doing sketch comedy had this up his
sleeve the whole time this is crazy but
yeah it's I mean it's one of my favorite
movies obviously it's number six on my
list but
it just did I think it also sort of
represented the cultural resurrection of
horror being a bringing horror back into
the mainstream in a really big way a lot
of people have seen a lot more horror
movies and horror movies are grossing a
lot more money at the box office because
get out and what it kind of did for
people getting like oh I get it it's
kind of like riding a roller coaster as
opposed to it just being a bunch of
horror fiends going in and watching
people get slaughtered in a movie
theater mm-hmm
my number six is my favorite well I
don't know if you asked me what my
favorite comedy is it's weird because I
have comedies higher than this one but I
think of this as more of my like if I'm
gonna go with like my the strictest
version of comedy that I'm gonna apply
to something then make that list I think
this is my number one a favorite is
straight-up comedy released in 1998 The
Big Lebowski well this would be higher
is your number six that's my number six
yep you thought it would be huh it's
high it's higher on my list than it's on
your list okay but so you thought that I
liked the movie bit more than you I
thought that it would I I thought that
it might be your number one honestly
yeah I mean at certain points in my life
it would be but there's other movies
that just they resonate they have more
meaning they touch my life and a lot
more areas this just kind of touches my
funny bone and my comedic Sensibility I
really regret not seeing The Big
Lebowski in theaters I think that was my
introduction to the Coen brothers this
was again I was taking this intro to
film class sophomore year in college I
was able to rent it because they were
talking about it in class
and I was like how have I not heard
about this movie it's absolutely
hilarious it's also very profane and
that's really edgy it was I wrote I had
to write a paper about ms on scene which
is basically arranging scenery and props
and I wrote oil paper I'm horrible at
writing papers but I had to watch the
movie again and again and again in order
to piece together this paper so I got
really acquainted with it but it never
got old the the performance is from Jeff
Bridges and John Goodman are just I feel
like they're perfect and then the ways
that they interact and you know it was
the first thing that I really started to
notice because I don't watch a whole I
don't watch a lot of movies again and
again yeah that's just not this is not
me but I but in such a short span of
time to do that and still enjoy it and
start to appreciate the nuances of
acting I think for the first time was
another touch point for this movie but
it was just it was just so funny and
still is so funny yeah I gotta say I
mean it's my number two Wow yeah when's
the last time you watched it it's been
years it's been years now and I was
talking to Locke about how we should
watch it together but I do I know that
one of the things that people discover
when they watch it and again come on
brothers are some of the favorite
filmmakers of all time I wanted that
them to have a spot and this is my
favorite Coen Brothers movie the reason
that it it's well a lot of people talk
about the fact that nothing happens and
I was actually reading an interview with
Joel Coen who says you know the plot is
sort of secondary to the other things
that are sort of going on in the piece I
think that if people get a little
confused it's not necessarily going to
get in the way of them enjoying the
movie so in this interview goes on to
talk about how like the plot is like the
fourth or fifth
thing because there's there's an
aesthetic quality to it there's the
characters the cut the dialogue is
incredible it's a situation as I mean
yeah baseball bat to the car with the
the homework under the seat you know
it's well and I think that it yeah I
struggle between like my bliss is a
combination of movies that do something
to me personally as a just a movie
watcher you know as an audience member
and then there are movies that do
something for me as an audience member
and an aspiring artist and so again when
I watch something that the Coen Brothers
make I think a lot of it has to do with
the fact that they're a duo
you know duo that's known each other
forever as being brothers and so I think
that when we look at them we think a lot
about our careers and you know we both
read the book about their sort of
creative process years ago and there's
just something a spur there's something
inspirational and aspirational about
them in their career and I feel like
this is like the pinnacle of where
everything came together in one movie
for them and so again it's the kind of
thing that and we all what we always
reference this we talked when we're
developing characters for ourselves and
some of the narrative stuff that we've
done we think about the dynamic we use
those three characters as points of
reference and a lot of the stuff that we
create like are you getting to Goodman
here is how bridges are you or how
Buscemi are you and is your character
you know I think that there's just
something about that trio of characters
the dynamics incredible yeah my number
two but I thought it was gonna be your
number one he's number two number six
Wow okay I'm very I'm very interested to
see where your list goes from this from
here okay okay my number five is again I
think it's a perfect movie back to the
future
back to the future love everything about
this movie yep a lot of people say it's
the perfect movie you know it it's not
the one where he goes to the future
that's a bummer no well a lot it's
interesting because when I watched it I
thought to myself I was like man this
movie has everything that I want in a
movie you know it's got this sort of
reality bending nature that if you're
gonna make a movie you might as well do
something mythical you know I always say
that something magical should happen so
you got that sci-fi element it's
incredibly funny and of course all the
choices that he makes part I just think
it's incredible the way that it
progresses in them but there's a lot of
people who point out the fact that Marty
McFly really doesn't grow or change
which is a really unusual thing which
would normally happen in a movie is that
it doesn't seem that he really learns
anything there's no like epiphany for
him really but yeah I just i watch this
fairly recently like in the past five
years and it was when it hit and you
know it's like man I never like I loved
this movie growing up but I just kind of
I loved it together with a lot of other
movies in that you know you got all the
Spielberg stuff and you and then is a
mecca of course did this one but it's a
very Spielberg II type a lot of people
just think that Spielberg made it I do
think he was a producer on it but
Zemeckis and then Robert Gale wrote it
together which this is a really
interesting thing I was reading about
this in a 2015 interview Zemeckis
maintained so he and he and zamek
Zemeckis and Gale own the rights to
distribution of the film and and the
rights for all sequels and they say that
both of them have agreed that no reboots
will be made as long as they are alive
huh so don't don't expect it's one of
those things and I love that because you
know they would screw it up it's one of
those
things that they would there's there's
movie studios that are chomping at the
bit to remake this movie knowing that it
would do really well at the box office
but there you just can't improve upon
the original this is just one of those
case usually can't but this is just one
of those cases that there's just
something sacred about it yeah it's the
ultimate time travel movie the and it's
the ultimate miss on my part you know I
think that that that movie the fact that
I didn't see that until college in its
completion maybe after college again is
just I know that's mind-blowing and it's
just you know you're deprived I'm a
childhood cut short or something I don't
know
okay so now we're at my number five okay
so this is where I've placed the Star
Wars trilogy and I have made a choice of
which one well yeah here we are at
number five with the Empire Strikes Back
I mean you can't argue I don't think you
can argue with that being the one that
you would choose if you had to choose
only one to watch or to rank as you're
number one of you know all nine of those
but I did actually I'm just gonna be
honest I did think a little bit about
the force awakens because for me
personally it was you know it was an
opportunity to see it I don't remember
seeing I think I can almost remember
seeing Return of the Jedi
in the theater so it was the force
awakens in that theater experience after
having waited so long and then it being
a shared experience with my kids and now
Lily is my whole family but most for
them most of all Lily is so into Star
Wars to create that experience and have
that with her it's why the force away
and it's just such a nostalgic movie
because it's you can argue this just a
remake of a new hope but I love that one
but I'm still putting the Empire Strikes
Back I I wish
I could have experienced that no I am
your father
moment you know for the first time it
actually experienced it that would have
been amazing but you know everybody by
the time we watched it we knew I don't
remember not knowing before I watched it
oh oh yeah I I've seen it I know I what
I know I saw I don't think I saw any of
the first in the theater because I mean
that was 77 80 and 83 right I think so
so right yeah I ended up watching all
those on VHS and I've never been I love
I I'm a I'm a fan of Star Wars and I
like the most recent I've been really
enjoy all the most recent ones but yeah
it didn't even get they just didn't make
ma durable mention because another
trilogy did which I have it I assume
that another trilogy also made your list
which I enjoy more which we've talked
about but you don't have to yes you
don't have to apologize when I put Star
Wars on your list of all the Star Wars
fans I think I think it's I the thing I
respect about Star Wars is what it is
the mythology and sort of the the
philosophy that goes into it and how it
translates it is so relatable and so you
can use it in so many illustrations but
the actual just sitting there and
watching the movie especially the
originals it just doesn't get me it
doesn't get me enough to get into my my
favorite movies but you know what does
another movie that you're not gonna be
surprised this on my list and I would
bet anything that is not on your list
number four Braveheart a Braveheart was
an honorable mention from me I remember
we were both really into that College I
remember you be really into the
soundtrack like you only said I had the
soundtrack and played it in my room now
I don't know if it was something about
the fact that
I felt this like connection with William
Wallace even because you know I always
thought I was Scottish even though I'm
more Irish but there's something it's
one of those movies where I get so again
nothing about the movie appeals to me
from the in the aspirational filmmaker
side it's one of those movies that I'm
just completely an audience member and I
am completely lost in the story and
every single thing about it I just you
feel like your heart is just like
beating bigger and bigger throughout the
movie and then the the ending of that
movie
oh the ending of that movie is just like
it's like the first time I remember like
almost like weeping to the point of like
shoulder convulsions in an in a movie
theater and it just something about the
way it emotionally connected with me at
that time in my life is and I and I was
talking to the boys we haven't watched
it yeah it's very intense yeah and it's
you know what it's also very funny
there's funny momentary really funny
here I borrowed those characters and
it's it's just sort of a it's a huge
milestone kind of accomplishment and in
filmmaking and just like an epic the
scale of it and the intensity I think
it's one of the first movies where there
was they just made the decision to be
like hey when we show people fighting
like it's gonna be real like there's
gonna be like people swords going in
thousands of people died because swords
really add to people yeah well
interestingly one of the things I was
looking at they talked about how they
had to reshoot a couple of the epic
battle scenes because a few of the guys
had on wristwatches and sunglasses and
they and they would like see it and it's
always seems like a myth cuz they could
just go and digital filled out but serve
to be flogged I mean at that point in
front of everybody
yeah yeah yeah you will be killed pull
their kilts up
just give him a knife Fany flogging but
flogging which brings me to my number
four I again
Braveheart was an honorable mention but
I had to put Apocalypto at number four
what an amazing Mel Gibson movie you're
joking
yeah I remember Mel yeah it was good it
was decent it was a very violent
I mean Braveheart is very violent but
anyway that's not my number four my
number 4 I know I'm gonna surprise you
here I'm throwing another Coen Brothers
movie up there and now you know what it
is oh brother where art thou went higher
two spots than The Big Lebowski from me
released in 2000 I I was a big Coen
Brothers fan by this point so I was
determined I was gonna see then their
next movie in theatres and I remember
just feeling it was weird I just had
this connection to this movie the first
time I saw it like and I really think it
had to do with the type of comedy it was
like that old timey comedy and like this
like the southern humor and just the use
of music I really felt like it was a
movie that we would have made I don't
know it was yeah something actually I'm
I feel this was a complete miss on my
part now that I'm thinking about it like
I don't know why that in all the lists
that I looked up to jog my memory
oh brother didn't didn't come up well in
uh Awards George Clooney won a Golden
Globe for best comedy actor and I think
I did I do think it won best comedy or
musical I don't as a and it won the
Grammy album of the year and won the
freaking the soundtrack one album of the
year because it was a soundtrack I was
incredibly curity beta every song
every song was great so yeah that this
the southern the comedy the the way that
the the history and the way that music
was such a part like at that point in my
life like I mean music so important to
me and there's been different points
when I thought I could I could be a
music historian not because I know a lot
of stuff but because I could I could see
myself investing what it took to be that
type of person and I felt like that's it
was kind of like watching there was a
documentary element to it I felt like I
was watching a Ken Burns documentary on
on you know country music in some
aspects and it so it resonated with me
on all those levels and in the comedy of
it and the characters and it was just
and it was fine you know it wasn't too
heavy so yeah like I said like I said I
love it
and I I don't know where I would put it
but it didn't even come into my mind and
putting my list together and now I've
started thinking I think I would have
made my top ten had I had I realized it
for all the reasons that you just I
demand a written apology - Ethan you'll
get all cohan well I put the big
lebowski at number two so yes true okay
number three we're gonna have some we've
got to have some crossover in the top
three we have to I think my number three
I had to pick one I picked the first one
the Fellowship of the Ring of Lord of
the Rings having recently watched the
trilogy again ie well I thought that The
Return of the King was my favorite but
in rewatching it they're actually in
reverse order now number one is the best
number two is the second best and number
three is the third best and they're all
incredible in rewatching it I was as we
discussed a few weeks ago just fully
engrossed we're still going through all
of the DVD extras which there's like
reams of that and like the kids are into
that like
said in this particular rewatching the
two times was that for you it is my
number two ok yours number two it might
have my number three says not mine I I
had I'm not my number three or number
one again it it's one of those things
like like we said a couple weeks ago you
you realize my first of all we read the
books and we were both big fans of the
books it's you know it's a completely
different thing that a Chronicles of
Narnia The Chronicles of Narnia were
probably my all-time favorite series
because of when I was reading at the age
I was reading it but it's for kids
yeah it's a kids book whereas you pretty
much have to be a teenager or older to
really I think get into the Lord of the
Rings I wouldn't read the books or until
the movie started coming out but I read
each book before the movie came out only
time I've ever done that
well I Game of Thrones I read all of the
books before I watched any of that and
it's it only helped especially yeah
especially because they were they were
so reverent of the books when they made
the movies and now as I've already
recommended the extended versions yeah
well it's the perfect that from a
literary standpoint it is the perfect
fantasy series it's been emulated but
it's never been superseded I don't think
and then like you said the the fidelity
that the movie that with the way that
they translated the books into the films
the level of detail the level of
attention is it's just something that I
don't think it had never happens before
it hasn't happened since no one's ever
adapted something with that much care
the way the way that you can watch a
superhero movie and I understand how
someone might feel like you know what
it's just a little ridiculous it's a bit
too much for me I just can't get into it
I think you could
say that about Lord of the Rings if it
wasn't Lord of the Rings but the fact
that it was it is what it is it has such
a deep well of backstory and history and
language and everything it's it's it's
easy to just immerse yourself in that
world and to because you can't be it
it's really hard to be critical of it
because it's done so well whereas if
it's not you can just roll your eyes in
that John that's what happened with
Narnia you know right okay so my number
three I've been on record I you
shouldn't be surprised I've been on
record saying this is the best movie of
all time and I it sounds like I'm saying
it as a joke
I can hear it made number three my
number three movie of all time
released in 2003 with no apologies from
me is elf know is one of is my third
favorite movie of all time you know I
didn't see it in the theater it said
that so many of my movies on my list I
didn't see in the theater but we watched
it of course we watch it every year at
Christmas and every year Christmas I'm
like forget how good this movie is one
of these years I'm gonna expect it to be
as good as it actually is every scene I
mean it taps into the nostalgia of the
of those old stop-motion movie Christmas
movies that we'd watch Rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer and Frosty the
Snowman to this moment
it pays perfect homage to those it's its
Will Ferrell in this like super sweet
mode that's just really winsome every
scene
oh yeah this one's this is a really good
scene and this is a really good scene
and it's the scenes build the movie in
some way it's kind of like I know that's
like a weird or maybe the obvious thing
to say but what I'm trying to get at is
it's not just
what
everything that happens you feel like
this is my favorite part of the movie
and then the next thing that happens all
no this is my favorite part of the movie
and you go through there's only a few
places where that's not really the case
like every every scene has something
that in that moment that you're watching
it makes you think it's the best it's
like listening to the hall and oates
greatest hits album when you're like oh
this is the best song and then the next
one comes on that's my experience in
watch enough it's and and then there's
there's all the memories of watching it
with my family every year and
everybody's still loving it nobody
rolling their eyes okay
it's a great movie and when we do top 10
favorite Christmas movies of all time
it'll be my number one but you don't
have to say anything you don't have to
say anything no no I mean I think it's
funny it's a funny movie but it's funny
or that it's your number three favorite
movie jon favreau wanted to he was
exploring making a sequel but Will
Ferrell didn't seem too into it it's
come up a few times over the over the
decades but it ain't gonna happen I
don't think it should happen I don't
want it to happen okay well I've already
told you my number two I've already told
you my number two which is around see oh
oh so we're going to number one but yeah
we obviously yeah we know what our
number one is right this this was the
thing that there was no there was no
question that I knew I was gonna put as
my number one it what that wasn't the
difficult part the difficult part was
filling the list out but well say it on
the count of three and we'll say it at
different times because of the delay
between our two video chats but three
two one
pulp fiction there it is released in
1994 Quentin Tarantino's follow-up to
Reservoir Dogs when I watched this movie
I went to it's interesting we didn't
watch this movie together
it was it was really gaining momentum it
had been out for a while
and I went to the Rialto Theatre which
is like in in Raleigh at like five
points where that like that's where I
saw it at the Rialto for the first time
but did I see it cuz you took me back to
it I think so I I know I didn't watch it
the first time with you I think I
watched it with Missy my girlfriend at
the time because that was nineteen it
might have been 95 by the time we saw it
cuz it took a while to get going and we
were was doing we were definitely dating
at the time but the funny thing is I
don't remember who I saw it with I
remember the theater I remember the
theater had a stage and it had these two
big speakers just exposed and sitting
out there below the screen and it it was
a small theater and you would just walk
down the sides and then go into the
middle really old rickety squeaky seats
and write it it just thought it was the
first time I had seen a movie at the
Rialto or any like art house theater and
I felt so out of place yet so cool being
there you know I was being in high
school and it was just like they were
there were these hipster college kids
and like these old guys wearing sweater
and you know cardigans like Professor
types and they were drinking beer in
their seats and it was and then the
movie started and it was in it started
and it's such a different way than any
movie I've seen it had this opening
title credit sequence I'm like what is
this yeah well he did he I remember the
feeling of after I watched that movie
and this has happened a few times where
you just got to sit there for a while
you can't get up well it was confusing
because it it was you know it was this
it was circular narrative as presented
out of order and so like well he was
just he was doing things that we had
never been exposed to first of all we
hadn't really seen anything that violent
you know in your face like I mean the
type of gratuitous good
- it is violence to the point and again
this is controversy on Tino's
controversial there's gonna be people
who are mad at us because we put this as
the number one but listen this isn't
we're not trying to please anybody with
this list we're just telling you what
our favorite movies are and I know
Tarantino's a controversial figure but
the impact that that movie had on me and
the fact that it he made extreme
violence funny and I don't know I know
that that's that's problematic and I
find I find that problematic and I
wouldn't personally create it but even
the the scene where they shoot Marvin
and it's actually the most horrific
thing that you can imagine but yet
incredibly funny at the same time he
Tarantino had this way of tapping into
this sort of dark part of every person
who wants to laugh at violence because
they don't know what to compute it the
thing that was funny was the carrot it
was in those characters worlds it was
just another day at the office
and it in so it's it was the most honest
way for those characters to react to
that accident and it was funny like I
mean the dialogue the dialogue is it's
unlike anything we had never experienced
that like the Royale with cheese
conversation that they have in the car
in the first half of the movie I
remember us talking about that and
thinking like no one's ever has ever we
had never been exposed to anybody who
would have this completely tertiary
conversation it would have weird
conversation ended it felt like there
was there was a resonance in the fact
that time was dedicated to two
characters having this strange
conversation and it's not moving
anything a lot and it really accepted it
because they were walking up and they
were armed that's you know depending on
what you know they were going to do
something all this tension was built
because discussion what what's happening
I find this extremely funny but it
also I'm really tightening up inside and
it was and I was aware of the filmmaking
process more so and than I ever had been
maybe completely for the first time that
like a directors voice could could could
move me and it so that was extremely
inspiring to to make a connection
between the decisions that a director
had made and the the experience that I
was having yeah well in another part of
that that I think you'll agree with is
when we made movies you know like mum we
made gutless wonders or whatever and
some of the stuff that we would start
filming and writing at the same time
growing up the we didn't think about
film scores as scoring right we didn't
think about people making music that is
intended to accompany in our minds the
way that we thought about film scores
with soundtracks we thought about yeah
songs that were cool that had a vibe
that you put into a certain part of the
movie and that's what Tarantino did in
that movie that soundtrack introduced me
to John Rizzo music I mean that
soundtrack
introduced me to Al Green yeah and and
from then on as like oh I'm an Al Green
fan you know and and every single song
was so carefully chosen and I think that
that resonated with us because the way
that we think about music and the way we
think about music and being mashed is
something on screen and he was he
continues to be a master at that but
that was something we even though I had
been done it hadn't been done in nearly
the same way and the fact that I mean it
basically if you if you're reading about
cinema and you're reading about this
movie you're gonna read about Pulp
Fiction being a cultural watershed
whether you whether you like it or not
so it I think it was so special to both
of us and became on number one because
we experienced personally firsthand in
moment the cultural watershed not just
for film but it it impacted so much more
ended to be at the age where it that
that watershed could happen through it
could run through our body just course
through our veins as we watch this thing
I I didn't know but I that I was the one
that brought you to watch the movie
again but I can definitely believe that
to be the case because I haven't
experienced it I knew that you had to
experience it and I'm glad that we both
went back there I just don't think it
was running anywhere else anyway or
maybe it was just the coolest place to
see it because it was still it was you
know it had 250 265 F words which set
the record by a long shot
I'm talking about 95 four years well but
the highest Tarantino's highest number
of f-words is 269 do you know what that
was inglorious basterds knows Reservoir
Dogs so he actually used to use the
f-word more then than he does now but
yeah I think it was it was one of those
things that interestingly even though
you know me and you come from a
conservative Christian background and we
were definitely like very serious
Christians at the time we never really
we didn't have a in a there's a big
aversion to cursing and violence and
that kind of thing and you know the
whole like tipper gore put parental
advisory there's a big aversion to a lot
of that at that time especially in the
90s but we never were really a part of
that we all we always kind of gravitated
towards those things that seemed a
little bit subversive maybe because our
personal lives were not there was
nothing subversive about any of the
things that we were actually doing so
maybe it was some of an outlet for us or
whatever but I think that that is one of
the reasons that
it it was controversial at the time it's
like you can't do that you can't say who
why would you use the f-word 265 times
in a movie and you know what it is
excessive but it's almost like that's
why he did it because it was excessive
that's why the their scenes in there
they're like why did you have to put
that in there and it's like exactly
because he was like I'm just gonna I'm
gonna do this almost as a as a way to
sort of shock you into welcoming my
style of filmmaking for better or worse
well there's there's more controversial
choices than that which we want I don't
want to get into but oh yeah yeah I
think it was a time in a place and being
a part of that experience puts it at
number one and you know what the what I
hate to go back to elf I got to go back
to elf if I may because I left out one
thing that I that I found you know the
burp where he like drinks the whole two
liter of coke and then he like does the
longest burp ever and he's like did you
hear that so funny right great movie it
was a real burp and it was from a
voice-over artist named Maurice LaMarche
who was the voice for one of my favorite
animated characters who made my my TV
movie list in that episode he was the
voice of the brain and pinky in the
brain and Animaniacs well he did the
burp for else well you know one the one
additional piece of trivia about elf is
there was one word that was also used
265 times in that movie it was the elf
word oh gosh okay so there you have it
that's is resist not as much overlap as
I thought might get happen and um you
know it's one of the Alysha so you had
obviously we had the same number one
and then we both had the big lebowski
both had fellowship of the ring yeah
and was that it I think that's it
my honorable mentions were Toy Story 2
her the peanutbutter Falcon Forrest Gump
and the other ones that I already
mentioned yeah let me quickly run
through mine those are good ones that
you just mentioned Groundhog Day
Rushmore Dead Poets Society the usual
suspects
The Matrix Fargo One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest Apocalypse Now Oh Forrest
Gump Raiders of the Lost Ark 2001 a
Space Odyssey the Shawshank Redemption
cabin in the woods cabin in the woods
which I'm going to be talking about on a
another YouTube channel Toy Story and a
Napoleon Dynamite you're going on whose
channel I'm going on dead meet James Oak
I don't know when that's coming out but
you talk about your favorite horror
movie and get out was too obvious of a
choice so I'm talking about cabin in the
woods yeah that's a good one all right
there you have it our honorable mentions
as well as our top tens I'm not gonna
give another wreck because this whole
episode is a wreck pick some of those to
watch with your your loved ones and
maybe we jog your memory to go back
hashtag your biscuits let us know just
don't watch Pulp Fiction with your
family yeah unless your family is all
adults right even then it'll get awkward
hashtag your biscuits let us know you
can put your top 10 just tweet it at us
we'd love to see that yeah yeah
tweet your top 10 will tell you if
you're right or wrong and will speak at
you next week to watch more ear biscuits
click on the playlist on the right to
watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe if you prefer
to listen to this podcast it's available
on all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]